Wherever you go from here you have to promise
to take care of that little boy for me
make sure he never forgets where he came from
pavakar he lives in a world we're calling Mom
baton which is based on these 70s comic books
in India the idea for this Dimension is that
it's Manhattan there it is spider Punk Voice
by Daniel kaluya so cool Hobie Brown he's um got
a lot of flair he's a really fun character Daniel
is he and Gwen are best buddies and they have a
rapport they're both musicians they're both like
badass and it makes miles feel a little jealous
that they've got this like uh this bond going on
between them and and he's a lot of fun character
Peter uh got back uh with Mary Jane and uh and
they had a baby Mayday baby May Day who was in
the film it is true she has like this she's half
spider blood in her so she's got some some spider
stuff going on parenting is hard enough when they
don't have the ability to stick to walls Welcome
back everyone it's Charlie Spider-Man across the
spider verse dropped another trailer lives like
a bonus trailer with a bunch of other characters
like spider punk so I figured I'd do a video just
for all the different versions that show up in
the trailer I named some of them in my previous
video I'll talk about all them during this video
and they're supposed to be over 240 characters
in the movie not all those are supposed to be
versions of Spider-Man but you can let me know
if you found 200 distinct versions of Spider-Man
in this first trailer if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
first big one is Spider-Man India we finally get
a look at him we went to his world in the previous
teaser trailer but we haven't actually seen him in
that other trailer yet this is what spider Punk is
going to look like they say that he actually has a
special relationship with spider gwen in the movie
because they're both musicians and the new shoes
that she's wearing in the trailer are given to
her by spider punk like those are spider Punk
shoes they also introduce special versions of
Haley Steinfeld in real life as as a version
of Spider-Man like her spider sona with her
two dogs those are her actual dogs in real life
done as versions of Spider-Man then obviously we
know Miles Morales is coming back saw him in the
trailer already talked about spider-gwen Peter B
Parker coming back who now has his child Mayday
Parker from the comics this is what she looks
like they reveal a better look at her in that
second trailer and obviously Spider-Man 2099 is
one of the antagonists that they introduced in the
teaser trailer he's featured very prominently but
then starting at the billion different versions
that they show at this Multiverse base of theirs
the name of their team that Spider-Man 2099
has put together is called the spider Force
they've assembled to clean up the damage that
the accelerator caused to the Multiverse in the
first movie so in the background of this first
shot here like before it zooms out there are
like 10 different versions on the left it seems
like there's a version of MCU Spider-Man kind of
hard to tell because of the YouTube compression
making it super blurry talking to a version of
the Canadian Spider-Man his suit was just like
the classic suit except it was red and black
instead of red and blue next to them is the
velocity suit talking to what looks like the
topi Maguire or Spider-Man they did say that
Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield Tom Holland would
probably have cameos during this movie so don't
be surprised if you think you spot MCU Spider-Man
Toby Maguire or Andrew Garfield's variant then
way in the back there's a version of the classic
red and blue suit just like the regular classic
suit from the original comics with another black
suit that might be a version of the anti-ok suit
some of these suits are also from the cartoons
the many many different cartoons over the years
too on the right it looks like the classic iron
spider red suit talking to the electro proof
suit in another black suit that's a little too
blurry to see which black suit it is then on the
far right there's one peeking around the corner
that's another red armor suit that looks kind of
like a version of the classic iron spider suit it
could be one of the spider armor suits too there
are a couple of those in the trailer then slowly
zooming out a little bit at a time because there's
so many versions here in this first frame it seems
like Earth 916211 Spider-Man who just wore a suit
that was similar to this behind him I can't tell
who this female Yellow variant is the there was a
yellow variant of the classic suit in the PS4 game
that looked kind of like this behind her seems
like a version of Spider-Girl wearing a variant
suit from The Amazing Spider-Man 1000 they were
from an unknown reality during that this is the
black and gold bulletproof Mark II spider armor
suit talking to what looks like the Bruce Banner
Spider-Man variant like the Hulk who became a
version of Spider-Man and just had a white and
blue costume like this in the middle here featured
very prominently is Spider-Man from the PS4 game
talking to Ben Reilly in a version of his ultimate
costume in the lower left hand corner I'm not sure
which one this red and blue symbol is but it
seems like a variant of the Velocity suit one
of the newer video game based suits to the right
of the yellow and black suit seems like a version
of the aim Spider-Man who had been brainwashed by
them then when you zoom out a little more these
two behind them seem like versions of Jessica Drew
and behind her is another version of Jessica Drew
in the red and white suit like a couple different
variants of Jessica Drew remember there's almost
like 200 versions of Spider-Man in this movie
so not all them will be variants Peter Parker
some of them will be variants of the other female
characters in the film as well pretty much anybody
in the comics the games any media that's ever put
on any version of a Spider-Man suit is in this
movie zoom out a little more this is steampunk
spider girl named Maybelle Riley talking to
another massive Peter Parker variant in a basic
red and blue suit they're a couple chunky versions
of Peter Parker and this some of them fat and just
some of them super swole on the left is spider cop
behind him seems like the mangaverse Spider-Man
these two girls are spinnerette who's a variant of
Mary Jane Parker that gets powers and her daughter
with Peter Parker named Annie Mae Parker to the
right this isn't meant to be naked Spider Woman
it's just a pink and red suit further to the right
there's what looks like a version of the fear
itself suit it's not exactly like fear itself but
it's pretty close talking to another classic red
and blue variant to the far right there's a big
group of them talking to each other the big one
seems like a variant of the flip side Spider-Man
he's talking to what might be another variant of
Jessica Drew in a similar red and white suit the
blue suit seems like the Spider-Man Fantastic Four
suit the classic one not the future foundation
suit that was white next to her there are two
more that I can't totally make out one of them is
another super thick version of Spider-Man zoom out
again you see the bombastic bag band next to him I
believe is a variant of Flash Thompson Spider-Man
from the comics wearing the Midtown High letterman
jacket behind them I'm not sure who the red and
yellow one is supposed to be this one above them
seems like the classic spider armor version above
him it seems like a version of one of the earlier
video games Spider-Man but I can't tell which one
it is over on the right there's another yellow
and black variant of what seems like the Antioch
suit on the far right this red and black version
seems like a variant of superior Spider-Man
above him the glowing yellow and black suit
is another video game suit I can't tell exactly
which one this is this is werewolf Spider-Man
pretty easy to spot zoom out again there's a
few more on the edges here so next to the yellow
Spider-Man seems like a variant of Spider-Man
UK above them seems like a version of Spider-Man
negative next to him the all blue Spider-Man
seems like another variant of spider cop the
chunky Spider-Man next to him seems like another
version of Earth X Spider-Man on the bottom left
this seems like a variant of silk then when
they all try to Dogpile miles morals like they
all start going at him they're in this exact same
area and most of the ones that are going after him
are the ones that I just talked about that were
sitting around casually but there are a couple
new ones in here this is Anya Corazon this is
superior Spider-Man this is six armed Spider-Man
who grabs him with all of his arms along with a
version of the classic spider armor this is one of
the newer spider armor suits it could also be the
fortnite version of Spider-Man 2. this one wearing
the business suit is Dapper Spider-Man who's
actually based on fan art and cosplay like not
all the versions I think in this are meant to be
Spider-Man from the comics the movies of the games
some of them are from real life fan art which
seems very much in the tone of the spider-verse
movies like some of the variants are going to be
the fan fiction versions of Spider-Man then this
isn't meant to be MCU Spider-Man Tom Holland this
is still PS4 Spider-Man the same red variant next
to him in what looks like a suit from the later
Secret Wars event this is Kane over on the left
for those of you hoping that Kane would be in
here there's also spider monkey up top I believe
this is a new variant wearing the tracksuit in the
regular shoes all the others are ones that I just
mentioned that were sitting around previously when
he starts web slinging towards camera one of the
new ones in this scene I believe is the Spider-Man
from the ultimate cartoon there are a couple
cartoon versions of Spider-Man like Spider-Man
from the 90s Animated Series this is the Manga
versus Spider-Man again trying to NAB him then in
my last video I already talked about the bigger
version of Jessica Drew they're doing played
by israe they're calling her jest Drew during
the movie and she is pregnant like the regular
version of Jessica Drew in the comics there's
some people that feel like they saw a version of
PS1 Spider-Man in here there's a version of cyborg
Spider Woman that we've seen in the toys but isn't
in the trailer here and even though I didn't spot
him in the trailer anywhere here I believe Andrew
Garfield will also have some sort of Cameo during
the movie even if it's only a visual Cameo for the
amazing Spider-Man but if you think you spotted
any other versions of Spider-Man in this that I
didn't talk about in the video like I said they're
supposed to be like over 200 versions so I only
mentioned a fraction of them and this trailer only
shows a fraction of them but part of the whole
thing in the trailer is that Spider-Man 2099 in
these other versions of Spider-Man really do not
like what Miles Morales is doing when the movie
picks up spider Gwen has been invited to join the
spider Force like this Multiverse Spider-Man team
but Miles Morales is not invited to join that's
why they had the voiceover in the trailer with
his mother talking to him about not letting other
people tell him he doesn't belong certain places
but I think part of the idea is that Spider-Man
2099 has gone so hardcore trying to fix the damage
from the reactor and he kind of blames miles and
the others for not stopping it sooner because all
the damage to the Multiverse that they're trying
to fix with the spider Forge is because of what
happened in Ultimate Spider-Man Miles Morales
Earth it also seems like Spider-Man 2099 lost
his daughter like she died at some point because
this is meant to be a picture of him I believe so
he's like the city miles version of Spider-Man
2099 like I've seen a lot of Spider-Man but the
way I talked about it in my last trailer video is
more of a Captain America Civil War situation the
spot character from the comics is meant to be
the actual villain of the film so we think all
the scenes in this trailer of Spider-Man 2099 and
the spider Force coming after miles are meant to
be kind of a misdirect but I'll do more videos
for the movie when we get more footage we hear
about more versions of Spider-Man more Easter
eggs there's a bunch of stuff coming up too make
sure to enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss it everyone click here for my full Spider-Man
across the spider-verse trailer video and click
here for my Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!